we want to touch on a few things related
to the financing process I guess early
when do you start fine
you know the financing process what's
the right process how do you get to that
first term you sheet and then sort of
how do you negotiate it was the best way
to optimize valuation insurance yeah so
so I'm a partner at IVP we're a later
stage fund only so most of the work that
I'm doing this investing in companies
that have already raised you know one or
two amounts of funding so that the
process is a little different for for
that stage and the earlier stage but I
think was with sort of applicable in in
almost every stage of a negotiation and
investing is that the investment process
is actually oddly like dating and I was
like terrible at high school dating so I
probably suck at this job too but but in
the dating process you know there's a
lot of especially if you're a company in
some sense you know you want to give the
appearance that that you've got a lot of
options from the investors out there if
you come to an investor and say you know
you're my only hope
I'm running out of cash in a week can
you fund me you know as much as that
might be attractive it actually you know
it's much better to say I'm not really
looking for investment right now I'm
taking my time but if I meet the right
person I meet the right investor I might
actually consider taking capital so
investors want to feel like like
investing in your company is a privilege
is something that is a scarce resource
and it's really important as an
entrepreneur to try to create that route
through the process and and really never
raise money when you need it raise money
when it can help accelerate your
business yes that's funny as a as
employer to start companies I would not
advise you go
and that's not the best strategy for
optimization how do you sussed out when
when I mean so obviously in the
negotiations of leverage is everything
there's perceived leverage and there's
an actual leverage as we see how are you
able to suss out when a company may not
actually have the options that the
present me what I mean I think we're we
don't like to play games with the
companies so I there's other firms I
talked to another investor who had this
great story about how how he actually
plays heart begin with a company and
he'll meet a company and they'll say you
know I would love to invest but you know
we're we're probably gonna be way too
low on valuation I'm not the right
investor you know I'm on all these other
boards yeah it actually makes the
company go no no you're you're right for
me I want to you know how can we work
together I don't like playing this game
so we focus a little more on on the
fundamentals of the business do we do we
like the business is it a strong company
and you know how do we feel after we
invest sitting at the in the boardroom
so we try to think a lot about you know
when you pull up a chair it's a board
meeting and you just paid you know 100
or 200 or 300 million dollars for a
company does that feel like you're in a
good starting position where you can
make money as an investor in and the
best investments aren't once where we
come out of it going oh my god we really
just got such a good deal I mean we
those guys are terrible negotiators the
best ones are actually where both
parties feel like it's a fair valuation
we're all starting in the place where
the entrepreneur gets what he wants
we're in a place where we can make money
and you don't want the entrepreneur
feeling like you know wow I just gave up
half my company that I didn't need to
know something yeah totally the
over-optimization game is one of the
things that that I talk to and counsel
entrepreneurs on is you know this isn't
a zero-sum game right you you you have
equity
built and the investors very much want a
piece of that might want their money but
you want to make sure they're the right
partner you sort of liken the
fundraising process to it to a dating
process how you how do you advise would
you advise be took your hat off put on
the entrepreneur helping to advise them
to evaluate potential eat seeds yeah so
one of the surprising things that that
very few entrepreneurs do are is
reference checking on the venture firm
so we spend all of our time digging
through the financials of a business
calling customers of a company doing not
you know in reference checks on
management and and we often offer up
references on our company on when we're
meeting a company because we want them
to do better understand us and you know
it's incredibly rare that a company
actually says you know I give me three
references and they not only ask you
know if you're if you're actually doing
reference checking you know don't just
ask for the references that the CEO or
that the venture firm gives you wants to
give you ask for specific situations
where the venture firm invested in a
company that didn't go out and find out
how they how they acted in situations
that were actually challenging you know
you learn a lot about a person not not
when times are good but actually it's
sort of the darkest moments when you
know they're worried about losing all
their money or the company needs to shut
down or there's big management changes I
think that's where we're really
adventure investors are worth their
their weight and you know I think doing
reference checking in those situations
is really critical and I think same with
with entrepreneurs you know I want to
hear about situations that actually
didn't work historically and have you
dealt with challenges right for
entrepreneurs it's one of the the three
information about the VCS is it's all
it's all online you know like
recommendation or all you're gonna give
somebody a reference that's you know
it's gonna say great things about you
but you can go around that you can go
you go you can find who who they
invested in who has and you could ask
them and you know to Jewell's point one
of the things you can do to sort of
manufacture you know not a hard to get
but at least present the position of
negotiating leverage is to ask those
budgets okay you know I'm also
evaluating you as a VC you know let me
let me check you out I'm not just here
for the taking yeah and I think like
creating you know it's interesting
around that point about how you get the
VC to move and this this idea of
actually creating artificial scarcity in
your company so if you're if you're a
company you're raising money the the
round that you're raising is actually a
really scarce event because if you're
raising five million dollars or ten
million dollars you know that's not
you're not a public company an investor
can't just buy your stock every day you
know there's a really great opportunity
to invest and so this idea of creating
this artificial scarcity and then
bounding that in time and so in an
artificial way so it's some sense you
know you need a million dollars the
message to investors shouldn't be I want
to raise a million dollars over the next
six months or a year because investors
will just wait as long as possible and
get as much information as possible this
idea of saying I'm raising a million
dollars I've got you know a bunch of
meetings this week you're behind so you
got to catch up and I'm gonna make a
decision we have a board meeting or I'm
gonna make a decision on next Wednesday
all of a sudden it as an investor you
feel wow I either have to move or this
opportunity is gone and it's not going
to be around for there a year or two
years when a company's next raising
funding and even better than creating
art
you know urgency is to run in front a
process running funders and process that
actually is designed to create actual a
lot of a lot of entrepreneurs a lot of
founders that I work with you know at
least until we talk have some sort of a
happy-go-lucky haphazard approach to the
fundraising process as opposed to you
know more but more of a structured
approach where you you target you know
three or four VCS who you're interested
in taking money from you poach them all
you start them along the process at the
same time because generally and you will
jump in upon the second year these take
you know they have this app but they
have the same processes that they go
through they evaluate they do they do
the business due diligence that there's
gonna be a partner meeting it's a two or
three week process of introductions you
even you essentially be in a position to
offer of attorney unless you're super
you know snapchat type company where
people are throwing em sheets at you by
the latter and what you'd like to do is
you'd like to have all all of those VCS
in that cohort that you're that you're
targeting ready or in a similar position
in terms of the process to so when you
get that first term sheet you're not
just you're not just sort of out there
you know twisting them way negotiating
with one person you can actually play
that off of the other pcs can create
that Perkins and I don't think that's
you know game playing and that's that's
sort of the you know that's sort of the
supply and demand you know yeah that's
funny like a mezuzah may we you know in
some sense it is some it is some game
plan it is artificial scarcity but as a
venture firm and maybe this is true of
gaming and some sense to like you want
to be you want to be played you want the
company to actually you know have the
sophistication to treat it like a
process to because you know what they're
doing things like that where they're
able to get people to invest it's going
to help you when the company is next
raising money of your net
it probably helps when they're
convincing clients and so you know the
ability of selling the sales role of a
CEO is critical in everything including
the fundraising process but I think
what's interesting I mean you talk about
that couple-week thing you know I would
not let the venture firm dictate the
time I would instead try to push the
firm as quickly as possible we actually
invested in in snapchat and also in
Twitter and Twitter we invested in early
2009 you know the company was initially
not thinking about raising money
we met the company on a Monday we
actually had an entire partner meeting
for her first beings of the company you
know we liked it so much we were there
all day on Tuesday and we had a term
sheet on Wednesday for the company so it
wasn't an all-time big process but we
know they said hey look if you can move
fast and and you're ready you know we'd
like to move forward so I think not not
sort of waiting on the venture firm but
pushing them to you know quickly yeah
and I think some of that is stage
dependence as well right if you're at a
later stage company you already have you
know investors who were members around
the table that you've you know and you
know other institutional investors and
you've got a track record that you're
buying off of it can be a much quicker
process because you're sure you've got
the right metrics that you can easily
benchmark you know for early-stage
companies grabs raising their first
round on the business side yeah it's
definitely true and you know I think one
of the interesting tactics especially at
the early stage side I had a you know I
was I went to visit the point to
undergrad at Yale in 2001 and I would
visit Stanford and one of the
professor's I had there was this guy
Andy Radcliffe who was a partner at
benchmark one of my ventures and someone
I really respect adventure and he had
this really funny quote about
early-stage fund raising and he says if
you ask an early-stage VC for money you
get advice because they make a lot of
times they say no but oh what you really
should be doing is this business but if
you actually ask
an early-stage venture firm for advice
you don't always get money but sometimes
you do so actually going to a venture
firm with the orientation that I'm not
looking for money and this probably true
also recruiting you know I'm not looking
for a job but I'd really like to to just
tell you more about my business and
every once in a while I mean when we're
meeting companies we know in the back of
our mind we might be funding them I mean
we're a value in that business and we
might say you know what actually I heard
the pitch I know you're not raising
money but is is there a way we could
have best yeah and then all of a sudden
you've shifted the conversation
questions
yeah and you know my advice to
entrepreneurs is is ask you know very
few entrepreneurs actually ask how do
you make decisions because some firms
especially earlier stage first if a
single partner wants to invest in the
company that partner will be able to
they'll have sort of an allocation they
can do one or two companies a year or if
it's a seed investment they don't need
approval from the rest of their partners
and so when they give you a term sheet
where they say I've invested in your
business you can take the word for it
yeah at our firm we're an equal
partnership we've got six partners but
we're all equal one partner one vote so
when we need to invest in a company we
need to get that company in front of our
partnership which is we talked about
Twitter isn't a difficult thing but we
need to do that and then literally after
the meeting we all sit around it and we
vote and doesn't make me stop doing our
work after the vote but it does give the
point partner authorization to move
forward and so we're actually I've had
trouble with companies and when Lions
are trying to be more explicit with the
process now is a lot of times I'll meet
a company I'll personally be excited
about it
they'll think wow the deal with IPP is
done and I'll need to tell them look you
know we're an equal partnership this is
the next step in the process I'm your
advocate I'm going to help you but
ultimately you know you need to convince
the entire firm and if you do convince
the entire firm you also get the full
resources of the firm behind you it's a
good thing for you as an entrepreneur
yeah in our portfolio i mean i think
yeah i mean i think i think everything
mobile i mean it's amazing i do so much
internet investing that that the
internet space the desktop internet
space is almost really started dying and
really it's everything's about mobile if
you look at the traffic patterns
underlying companies a lot of traffic's
moving to mobile so so we really like
invested in snapchat about a year ago
because we really like the the trends of
that becoming the social platform of
choice for teens and ultimately i think
for everybody and the new update i know
that's got a lot of grass i think is
awesome and i think more and more people
of my generation I mean my mid-thirties
will well I think I eventually start
using snapchat so I think that's that's
really important and I think it also
helped with our Twitter investment we
like that it was a mobile first platform
so we're seeing a lot of stuff in mobile
you know I'm a huge fan of freemium
business models or or sales models in
the enterprise that don't require
significant sales and heavy a sales
investment and I think it's interesting
where you know we're I don't know if
people are following the multiples in
the stock market now or watching
everything decline but you know for the
longest time nobody was focused on sales
of efficiency of enterprise companies
it's only almost didn't matter how much
you were burning you know if you're
burning 50 million or 100 million as
long as you're growing you're fine I
think was starting to change we're
starting to see that change that people
are starting to dig into well how
efficient is a dollar of sales or
marketing expense in your business it
was the return on that and so that's why
I tend to like models that just have you
know beautiful software or beautiful
product that's that's simple and easy to
to buy so I think that's a trend metal
to see more and more in the enterprise
yeah I really might graduated at one so
I got to ride the bubble all the way
down which is not fun so I had a word
for a bank called Robertson Stephens and
half of our analyst class so I got my
offer in 2000 half of our analyst class
had their offers rescinded before we
graduated the week before the DL
graduation my roommate who was moving
together he had his offer rescinded
so it was uh it was a terrible situation
and uh but now I think it was really
different and if you look it like I've
seen some stats recently if you look at
the the median revenue me like revenues
of a company that went public in 2000 I
mean it was like the technology was like
sub 20 million it was so small and today
it's 100 million so that the type of
company is better so I don't love the
term bubble butt but we were in an
inflatable environment where companies
that were doing 100 million dollars of
revenue or even 10 million for being
valued at multiples and valuations that
were so much higher than they probably
wanted to have been and and that's
contracted by 30 to 50 percent in the
last month here versus definitely yeah
you'd probably see a - I mean I mean
venture fronts are like behind the
conservative there's a reason that that
we're doing this job where we get to
invest in like 10 or 20 companies
instead of like putting all of our our
life into one business and when you're a
little more conservative you tend to
like businesses that have visibility of
their revenue which is a good thing so
having a recurring revenue model
eh
I think you said it so let me said I
like that yeah I mean it's it's just its
inherent in the investment I'd like you
said there there isn't going to be a
sort of a call right on the on the
series a if they're making a serious
seed investment but it's definitely
something to it's definitely something
to keep in mind if you want to you know
sort of diversify that by taking you
know money from a couple of institution
so that you can at least have one of
them leave or participate in the next
round that's great you know I will say
there is there is you know among
entrepreneurs doing serious seed rounds
a lot of times they'll the Scots hey
should we avoid taking an institutional
investors money for that exactly that
reason we can cobble together a little
bit less money but from from less
marketing should we do that and I think
the trend is leaning that way yeah don't
just take one investor if you take one
investor and they don't invest one
institutional investor they don't invest
it's a really strong signal but if you
take two or three yeah and then they're
all fighting against each other to be
able to leave here
don't take strategic money early early
alright well just do one more question
and then US strategic investor or okay
it's a great question so I you know I I
would say that strategic start investing
for different reasons than institutional
investors their strategic for reasons so
let's say they're a big retail company
they may want this ability and kind of
new trends or products of your business
they're gonna guide you in ways that may
not be the best way to maximize the
ultimate value of your business they
also are very slow to close and they
will often ask for rights around
Jonathan is better than me but like
rights around a right of first offer or
right of first refusal on an acquisition
that reduces your choice as a chilling
effect for other potential acquirers
down the line if they have a writer
George negotiation to write a pursuit
piece alone company and they'll always
ask for them cool thank you Jonathan and
Jules